the inbound helicopter is returning from
syria as soldiers are ordered to come
home from other fronts their mission in
the us-led coalition will continue in
syria
the biden administration is committed to
retaining u.s military presence in
northeast syria
on the ground every few weeks u.s
soldiers ferry equipment and supplies
from iraq to northeast syria
itself is the most important mission
for us because that keeps that barrier
to
help so that way if
isis does come back into another region
we're able to keep them back
just under a thousand troops are left in
syria to safeguard oil facilities and
continue efforts against what's left of
isil the u.s military says it's winding
down operations in iraq and afghanistan
but inside syria u.s troops continue to
play the role of trying to secure the
area and make sure that isil fighters
are not resurging the current surrenders
and fleeing of afghan forces and the
debacle of u.s withdrawal from iraq in
2011 has again put the capabilities of
u.s back forces under the spotlight
u.s partners in northeast syria are
mainly kurdish syrian democratic forces
or sdf in addition to agreements with
u.s forces the sdf made a deal with
russia in december to deploy russian
troops to towns near the turkish border
most sdf fighters are from the kurdish
people's protection group or ypg
linked with the kurdistan workers party
also known as pkk it's a complicated
composition turkey considers the ypg a
terrorist group and the pkk is
designated as terrorists by the united
states and the european union
the sdf also controls jails for isil
detainees
last year a u.n commission of inquiry on
syria said the long-term internment of
allegedly isil associated individuals in
the northeast by the sdf amounts to
unlawful deprivation of liberty in
inhumane conditions
in 2019 human rights watch found women
locked up without charge in the open air
alcohol camp testimonies spoke of armed
mass guards from the kurdish forces
arresting boys older than 12.
things have reportedly improved since
then u.s forces say they have faith in
sdf but have no oversight
now as far as for
all those you know those types of issues
i have no visibility of that right um
so because i don't partner with them and
again this was just observing from a
distance um
what what
because i own that battle space
right of northeast syria and it tells me
that they do have the the capabilities
conduct complex operations
on the invitation of the coalition al
jazeera tried to enter the area under
sdf control but the u.s military was
stopped by the group a senior member of
the coalition told al jazeera the sdf
said no to your visit to syria it is
their country so oir will comply we will
cancel the syria portion
kendall scott first came to the middle
east 33 years ago he now leads 2000
troops spread across four countries the
sdf decision to block access came as a
surprise to him as well
now if you're asking me if a area
continuously you know locks down on all
its media and prevents well of course
there's always concern about that i mean
that's you know
the american concept is the freedom of
the press you know i mean we we support
that and understand it
as the tiger brigade gets ready to wind
down its deployment questions still
remain about detainee abuse media
freedom and human rights in areas under
the control of partners they have
trained armed and will eventually leave
in charge
with al jazeera air bill military base